what more can i say
well welcome to l.a
it's exciting stuff
on to the next chapter
if you guys want to engage
i'm watching the chat
so
we have a fireplace
that's quite nice
we have a lot of epic
content lined up for you
we are
incorporating new technology
this is pretty cool this is
just the iphone camera
we're using and
you can see that here
and that's
shout out to
new tech for their
newest build that incorporates a very
sleek
iphone application via the ndi
wireless connection it's quite nice
as you all know
we
finished
a massive cornerstone project in our
evolution
that project is called high level
perception
it's available for free
highlevelperception.com
it's also available on our youtube
channel
the whole book takes about 20 minutes or
so to get through
if you do it yourself on the website and
it's just 20 visuals it's an artistic
compression distillation of the most
profound things
that i've learned
i think in many ways it's the future of
communication
it's what generation z and generation
alpha wants it's what
michelangelo william blake
one could argue that the greatest
artists of all time
were in fact the greatest distillers
they were the best compressors of
abstract
concepts
into relatable
memes
it's a lot of what we're focused on here
in la
is
becoming the absolute best at
memes
becoming mimetic gods
so we have many components
we have the component of
interviewing
people in los angeles that have the
highest clout
the most influence the most fame
asking them humanity's most thought
provoking questions
this means things like
hearing what people like
kanye west or justin bieber
or taylor swift have to say about what
they think the nature of reality is
what they think the nature of
consciousness is
how they think we can architect
our social fabric to maximize human
potential
and unpacking their journeys
their wisdoms
and that's interviewing
and then we have
the dissemination of
the most profound things that i've
learned the continued dissemination of
it so it'll be more
of me talking to you directly
with notes with visuals
with things that come along the ride
with us to help you
fully grasp
the profundity visually of what we're
trying to communicate
so you'll get a lot of those streams
that we'll be doing
you'll get a lot more documentaries
we're working on anthologies we're
working on
animated series we're working on
becoming
the go-to destination for
everyone on the planet to
disseminate their memes
in a way that is
relatable
inspirational engaging educational
compressed distilled
today i was on the phone with a buddy
we were talking about applied
cryptography
he was giving me a very powerful analogy
to understand
fully homeomorphic
encryption so
in order to understand something like
fully homomorphic encryption
you need a really powerful analogy you
need really powerful visuals
for the masses to get these things to
understand what
a snark is in cryptography as well
can you compress that down to two
minutes
in an animated video and teach the world
an
analogy for understanding homomorphic
encryption and snark
so i see that
some people are commenting about the
volume
thanks for bringing that up so some of
our
accessories have yet to arrive including
the
windscreens for the audio technica mics
so those will be coming in soon
i'm also getting a fourth inch to
auxiliary adapter for the
allen and heath mixer we have so i can
hear the
the playback
there's a lot of interesting nuance that
goes into
running a full-scale
video production facility
and it's interesting because video
production used to cost millions of
dollars and it used to be kept
out of the reach of the public
and it's great because a lot of that has
changed
so now you can get a really nice
video production setup for under 50
grand
and you can stream whatever you want
whenever you want
via technologies like the tricaster
directly to a content delivery network
this complex
i'm still a kid at it but it's a lot of
fun
it's a great learning experience
we have moved our recording studio
from san francisco to los angeles after
spending
since i was 19 in san francisco
so i've been there nine years
and
traveled a lot did a lot of
different startups trying to figure out
what my gifts are and i landed on
simulation interviewing
different minds at the edge of their
fields and trying to make their
wisdoms relatable
just last week we moved down to la i
love los angeles
i've been here many times i've been
interviewing here
a lot actually a lot of from brilliant
people here
i'm really excited for you guys to
see the show back in an interview a day
mode because it's been a while since
you've gotten an interview a day
i published the interviews from
new west summit american anthropological
association
transformative technology conference and
our three weeks
in china i published all of those
interviews basically
at the end of 2019 and beginning of 2020
and trickled those out
and so it's been you know 10 months
it's been a long time
and i know what that's like i know what
that's like because when you're used to
an interviewer and you're used to them
bringing on really good guests
it's important to
have them be able to continue producing
content on a regular basis in order for
you to feel like
you're able to continue digesting the
wisdoms
that they're trying to communicate
i hope you found value in the fact that
after
700 interviews in two years that i took
time to synthesize the most profound
things i had learned
and give you that as a piece of content
and then make this move
well
i'm just really excited i'm really
grateful that we have all you we had a
bunch of comments about what i think of
bitcoin
why we left san francisco
we had some good luck thanks guys
in short i'm very very
bullish on cryptocurrencies
very bullish and
there's nothing quite like biomimicking
the decentralization
that exists with things like mycelial
networks
mycorrhizal networks the way that they
have a two-way resource exchange with
plants underground
that's billions of years of wisdom right
there
so
it's going to be exciting having a
frictionless exchange of value across
the planet it's very exciting
we had saturated san francisco decently
well
and there are a lot of brilliant people
in san francisco so it's
quite hubristic to even say that we had
saturated the
the bay area but we had done a decent
job at
exploring the different you can call
them
nodal clusters in the bay area we did a
really good job at that
so we explored those we
learned a lot and now it's time to take
our biggest questions to los angeles the
place with people with the biggest clout
as you guys probably know in 2018 2019
i wasn't so obsessed about the nature of
reality and the nature of consciousness
now more than ever i'm obsessed about
those two things
and so which are really one thing
and so i'm bringing
that most first principled question
right into the heart of
the most influential people on the
planet very genuinely
very authentically very lovingly very
skillfully
and then having them
evolve and awaken more to that
as well as have their large audiences
who watch them and follow them
awaken to the nature of reality and
consciousness
at a deeper experiential level
so it's super exciting stuff very pumped
super grateful that we have all these
different
diverse people around the planet that
watch us that care about what we do here
thank you so much i hope you guys
enjoyed high level perception
that the physical copy of high level
perception
will be published before christmas
we're aiming at around december 10th for
that to be available on amazon
and many other outlets
and i'm working with a really strong
team
that's really well versed in this
process and so
they're going to help redesign
the website that i built myself at a
super high level
of like 2025-esque design
as well as do a bunch of dissemination
of content that inspires people around
the world to check out these
compressions of wisdom in art
the 20 images and then be able to
have people from around the world pick
up the book
share it with their kids share it over
christmas
get it as a gift keep it on the table
revisit some of the images build on top
of it
so it's a team effort so super excited
for that
you'll see more of these los angeles
interviews pouring
out from the mid to late november
so from mid to late november we're going
to be live streaming interviews
approximately daily
and same thing december and 2021
onward so you'll keep seeing those
and just hyper grateful again
thanks so much you'll see me doing a lot
of art
so basically one of the main things that
happens in
podcast conversations is just two
talking heads
but instead of just two talking heads
i am going to be
playing with something really
interesting which is taking
this angle from behind me
onto what i will be sort of here
artistically composing so
i will be live
creating art about what
our guest is teaching us
and you will be able to see
the art that i'm creating through that
angle
camera angle and we'll have
the four shots as well in one screen
of all four angles as well
and the guest and i will be discussing
the concepts and the art that i'm making
that way what we're trying to do is
we're trying to constantly draw
out what is the most salient and what is
most
relevant and what is most wise
from the dialectic between us
it's something that all of the top
podcasts
don't do yet and i highly recommend
mimesis
here copy this idea
please we need podcasts to have
art happening that is drawing out what
is most salient from the three-hour
conversation
and then also what it does is it keeps
for example when you're talking about
consciousness
and their perspective about it you're
able to really
stay on that point rather than venture
off into
the where the monkey mind usually runs
away
after just a couple minutes on the
subject and then all before you know it
you're talking about something that's
completely less relevant and exciting
so so stay tuned for that as well
wow that's really nice comment
guy thank you said high level perception
is freaking amazing
it's a lindy book it will still be
relevant in 50 plus years
that's very very very kind of you thank
you
for those that don't know lindy is a
concept of naseem to lab
so it'd be very very awesome if uh
if we can inspire more people to create
things a very high level genius
that instead of disappearing in the
transient 24
7 evolutionary pacer of modernity
especially with the information
technology age
if we took the people that are several
standard deviations up the bell curve
and had their art be
focused on being lindy so that
everything that they build
lasts a year 10 years 20 years 50 years
100 years
really focus on it whatever
the pseudonymous deployment of satoshi
nakamoto and the decentralization
technologies happen
what do you think how long will
decentralization technologies be with us
for the rest of time for the rest of
this
cycle
so it was actually quite revelatory
mostly it was just an unveiling it was a
titration of
our our pinnacle
direction
of where we could possibly head to
maximize prosperity
again it was very bio-mimicked so it's
exciting stuff
love you guys very much thank you get
pumped for la i'm so pumped
so grateful i've had a lot of
very beautiful people in our lives here
already that have made tremendous impact
on the world that are
helping us make sure that our impact
continues at the super high
rate that is possible so love you all
very much
huge things ahead build the future
manifest your dreams into the world
we love you very much investigate your
consciousness
and watch yourself become more
enlightened
much love peace
thanks everyone